hi everyone and welcome to biology
professor today we're going to be
talking about the acid bath stain now in
the laboratory when trying to identify
different types of bacteria in the given
sample the most common type of
differential staining used is called the
Gram stain it differentiates between
gram-positive and gram-negative cells
based on their cell wall characteristics
if you're interested in learning more
about that you can either see my video
on the ground positive versus
gram-negative cells or you can also see
my video on the Gram stain procedure now
interestingly there are some types of
bacteria that they just can't be
distinguished with the Gram stain these
are called gram and determinant bacteria
for example there are some types of
bacteria that they have grand positive
cell walls meaning that they have that
characteristic thick peptidoglycan layer
covering a plasma membrane and then they
lack gram-negative cell characteristics
for example they don't have the outer
membrane and they don't have any help
yes but their grandma determinant it
just don't stay well with the Gram stain
the reason for this is that these
bacteria contain something in their cell
wall called mycolic acid
and bacteria that have mycolic acid in
their cell wall are referred to as acid
fast bacteria and they can be
distinguished from non acid fast
bacteria by the acid fast stain the
mycolic acid component is this really
waxy lipid component that is in a cell
wall and it's what prevents the Gram
stain reagents from accurately staining
these bacteria however there is another
dye that can be used the acid fasting
called caramel Dietzen carbocation is a
red dye it's used first and it will
actually die all of the bacteria and a
sample this red color the next step is
the use of acid alcohol
as in alcohol is a decolorizer for non
acid-fast bacteria treatment with acid
alcohol will make the red purple Hughson
die come out of the cell wall so that
the cell wall is colorless however
caramel houston is much more soluble in
mycolic acid then it is an acid alcohol
this means that despite the use of
active alcohol acid fast bacteria that
have Aldus mycolic acid they stay red
the final step of the acid fast name is
to use a counter stain this is just some
stain that will allow the non acid fast
bacteria to be visualized a little
better
the most common counter paint used with
acid fastings is methylene blue
methylene blue of will stain non acid
fast bacteria blue while the acid fast
bacteria still have all of these caramel
tips and die thus they renamed red so
now under a microscope acid fast
bacteria can be differentiated from non
acid past bacteria with this stain a
very common pathogen that is identified
by use of the acid fast stain our
species of Mycobacterium these include
my bacterium tuberculosis which causes
tuberculosis also Mycobacterium leprae
which causes leprosy so this is the main
stain for identifying those pathogens
and human samples